[Musique]
un endroit insolite pour terminer cette
première journée dans les hauts-de-seine
en passant par asnières philippe
vilamitjana s'est en effet arrêtée dans
le cimetière des chiens qui accueille en
fait les sépultures d'animaux très
variés pour quelles raisons avez vous
enterrer votre animal ici c'est petit
pour pas qu'ils soient brûlés aux
rythmes binaires qu'est ce que c'est
comme animal cergy lyon au lycée j'ai un
grand talent lab a paraît il ya 13 ans
c'est cher pour enterrer un animal ici
non ça m'a coûté cher ça oui ça coûte
l'ingénue pour 250 mille abeilles avec
le granit et tout et vous venez souvent
de tester
pompon colombo noir zizi et bobby au
post ici avec 3000 de leurs congénères
édifié en 1899 par la journaliste
marguerite durand le cimetière des
chiens d'asnières reste d'abord une
curiosité du département tous les
animaux peuvent trouver ici une dernière
demeure du serein au sein de la poule au
cheval l'enterrement
car il s'agit bien d'un enterrement
coûte entre 300 et 800 x ensuite le prix
des monuments car il s'agit bien de
monuments peut aller jusqu'à 5000 francs
[Musique]
qui pour payer tous les ans le même prix
c'est à dire combien à écoutez moi je
paye 485 40 mai
c'est un peu cher quand même le
cimetière est en fait une société
anonyme sept personnes travaillent ici
en permanence salaire d'un fossoyeur
autour de 3000 francs alors qu'il vient
ici porté son animal souvent des
personnes âgées pour qui le chien ou le
chat était d'abord un compagnon est
souvent l'unique compagnon véritable
culte qui semble sans limite
si ce n'est celle de l'article 8 du
règlement tout emblème religieux est
absolument prohibée
[Musique]